-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with
Kimberly Williams-Paisley
and Ashley Williams.
This is very cool.
These are two separate movies.
It might be confusing because we
can only show one clip.
But you guys have been doing
this both for a long time.
You've never acted in films
together before.
-Never.
-And you got to do two movies
at the same time. How did this
come together as an idea?
-This is Ashley's idea.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it was.
-Okay.
-Yeah, I mean,
I've wanted to work with
my big sister my entire life.
I was her first fan before
all y'all came in here.
[ Laughter ]
So, you know, it was
a dream come true.
And I came to her,
and, you know, I just --
This is my best friend,
my closest confidante,
the first phone call I make
when I'm crying
or when I have good news.
And so I had this idea
that what if she was
the star of one movie
and I was the star
of another movie,
and then our story lines sort of
wove back and forth throughout?
Which is kind of like a metaphor
for our lives.
Like, I'm this lead of the movie
of my life.
And she's the secondary
character.
[ Laughter ]
And she's the lead of her movie
and I'm her best friend.
-Mm-hmm.
-So we just did that.
And it was -- Hallmark was
so supportive of the idea.
They were really,
really thrilled.
-We pitched it
like five years ago,
and it took a really long time
to figure out
how exactly they need to
weave together.
-Sure.
-You know?
And just to get them going,
but we finally did it.
And we produced, and Ashley's
husband Neal produced as well.
-Mm-hmm.
-Brad wrote a song.
-Brad wrote a great song
and Kelleigh Bannen sings.
And it's just a beautiful --
Yeah, it's a beautiful part of
the movie.
-One of the things I've learned
about Hallmark movies
in recent years is that you --
they are shot in the middle of
the summer.
-Yeah.
-And in, like -- This was Utah.
-Super hot.
And we're, of course, like,
in winter coats, you know.
-Right. This is actually --
So this is a real shot?
So you had a snowman and you had
to put an umbrella over it
'cause it would've melted.
-Our snowmen are such divas.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's like, "What about us?"
We're, like, sweating, but, no,
it's all about the snowmen.
-No one's holding an umbrella
over our heads, yeah.
So, yeah, because -- we had to
source the snow from local --
Where did we get our snow?
-Snow farms.
-I think a fish market. Yeah.
So we -- And it was just blazing
sun, so we had to shield them.
Yeah. Protect them.
-And how are your boys?
How many kids do you have?
-I have two. I have two boys.
We only make boys.
-Okay, you make boys.
-And we have a brother Jay
and he has three boys.
So we have seven boys.
-Will your kids watch this?
Will they be excited to see
moms and aunts
in the same film together?
-Yeah, my 7-year-old watched --
The first movie,
"Sister Swap: Hometown Holiday,"
aired last night,
and my 7-year-old watched for
I think like 65 minutes
and then really politely said,
"I don't want to hurt
anyone's feelings,
but can I just do my own iPad?"
[ Laughter ]
Which I thought was --
But I get it.
He's 7, you know, he's 7.
-It's very nice that
he understood that
it might hurt feelings.
-Yeah, well, he knows
his mother. I mean, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And my kids watched,
yeah, they watched last night.
And I'm sure they'll watch yours
as well.
-Well, it's fine.
-They're devoted fans.
[ Laughter ]
-Kim, that wasn't
super convincing.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And you know what?
I'm sure they will.
-I'm sure they would
try to watch.
-They'll be very excited.
-I'm sure they would think about
watching yours. Yeah.
-We got to watch it together
last night, which was super fun.
And we dropped in on a bunch of
Zooms and said hi to fans
who were watching,
and that was fun.
-It's great.
It's really a lovely tradition,
and people who care about
these films love them so much.
And it's so cool to bring
something new to it.
It's such a unique idea.
-Yeah, it's cool.
And last night we got to
watch the movie
with a very close family friend
named Anna Holbrook.
I'm not sure
if you guys are familiar,
but she was a soap star.
I first met her when I was 5.
-Yeah, I met her when I was 12.
She took my first head shot.
She was an actress, amazing,
and our mom's best friend --
-For 35 years.
-And our mom passed away
five years ago,
so to have Anna Holbrook
playing our mom
in these movies was,
like, unbelievable.
And she's so great in it.
-She's amazing.
So we popped champagne
last night.
-Yeah, we did.
-Just delighted in
our own performances.
[ Laughter ]
-We also have Kevin -- Yeah.
We also have Kevin Nealon.
-Yep.
-Who I know is a friend of
all of ours as well
and his wife Susan Yeagley.
-Susan Yeagley was in it.
-So we just, like, padded it
with all of our friends
that we love so much.
-Well, it's great, and it
definitely shows up on screen.
And, you guys, it has just been
such a delight
to have you both here.
-It's so good to be here,
thank you.
-Thank you so much.
You guys, give it up for
Kimberly Williams-Paisley
and Ashley Williams.
Check local listings
for reairing details.
"Sister Swap:
Christmas in the City"
will premiere this Sunday
following the reairing of
"Sister Swap:
A Hometown Holiday"
as part of Hallmark Channel's
Countdown to Christmas.